pour parler nous sommes avec yannick
tennessee secrétaire général du fc metz
ppp ats syndicat des pompiers
professionnels de france bonsoir yannick
était dit merci d'être avec nous alors
vous vous n'étiez pas sur cette
manifestation puisque vous étiez place
beauvau avec le ministre on l'a on va
évidemment y revenir sur ses
revendications vous avez d'ailleurs
obtenu il ya plusieurs jours déjà je
vais vous faire réagir sur ces images de
vos collègues même s'il ne l'est pas
forcément du même bord syndicale avec
les affrontements avec la police avoue
ne développe pas à ça nourrir de
toujours c'est toujours choquant de voir
qu'il peut y avoir des affrontements
avec des gens avec lesquels nous
travaillons tous les jours alors pas les
crs mais tous les toutous les services
de police nous travaillons avec eux tous
les jours et de voir que effectivement
dans le cadre de maintien de l'ordre
on empêche les pompiers de dérivés de la
manifestation et que en face on n'a pas
toujours des enfants de choeur
effectivement les pompiers signer
gaillard aussi et puis à ils réagissent
la police eurent réagi et ça donne
malheureusement ces scènes mais on vous
tenter de l'expliquer en résumant mais
comment comment on peut expliquer qu'on
a des pompiers et des policiers nous le
dit qui sont normalement plutôt entre
nîmes et ont parlé quand c'est préfet d'
et police qui parlait de deux camps sont
plutôt normalement dans le même camp des
fonctionnaires là au service du citoyen
a priori qu'est ce que ça dit
sur le climat actuel écoutez sursaut
climat je vais pas j'ai pas vous
raconter d'histoires c'est on a quand
même des sapeurs-pompiers qui sont un
petit peu à bout parce que ça fait
depuis le mois de juin que la majorité
d'entre eux sont en grève et puis
ensuite toutes les corporations
syndicales en grève depuis le mois
d'août avec des avancées qui n'étaient
pas présentes et à un moment où les
pompiers ont ils en ont un peu assez
d'être baladées et ils vont finir par
avoir des gestes un petit peu des zeks
d'exaspération et puis montrer leur
mécontentement
on imagine la même chose du côté des
policiers qui on le sait sont souvent
présentés commençons france entre
guillemets c'est toute la fonction
publique aujourd'hui qui souffre
effectivement on en est on est tous là
les les collègues policiers ont exprimé
depuis le mouvement des gilets jaunes et
même bien avant des difficultés dans les
effectifs des difficultés donc à à faire
leur travail correctement ne pas pouvoir
poser leurs jours de repos
bon tout ça c'est c'est quelque chose
qui va qui va un petit peu tiré sûr sûr
sûr le seul policier et sur le pompier
est en fait c'est vous que la souffrance
de la fonction publique en france
on peut parler des hôpitaux on n'est pas
dans le même genre on n'est pas sur le
terrain entre guillemets
mais il accueille tout aux urgences il
accueille dans les hôpitaux dans les
cliniques et eux aussi sont en
souffrance en sous-effectif c de la
fonction publique qui va pas bien en
france est ce que pour vous c'est une
première ça fait longtemps j'imagine que
vous êtes dans dans ce métier est ce que
ce climat vous l'avez déjà ressenti
aussi explosif entre guillemets pour la
fonction publique non non non ça fait ça
fait ça fait depuis quelques mois
quelques années qu'on voit effectivement
que les leçons que la fonction publique
est en souffrance qu'on a toujours les
mêmes réponses que face à des mouvements
de grève qui viennent après la
négociation qui n'a jamais lieu
finalement ou alors cédé fin de non
recevoir
on vous reçoit on vous dit que vous êtes
gentils on dit vous êtes mignon que tout
est légitime et on n'a pas l'argent pour
vous payer donc il arrive un moment
c'est bien légitime et puis on ne paye
pas et donc tout le monde est en
souffrance a créé des mouvements tels
que les gilet jaune
on laisse pourrir des situations on
laisse le mouvement s'étendre et puis
après on discrédite à cause de la
violence et c'est d'ailleurs quand on
voit des images le police pompiers ont
dit bah tiens et à la violence
et puis pour le coup on parle plus trop
du fonds essais et c'est embêtant nous
on veut plus parler du fond que que de
ces quelques scènes qui puisse y avoir
mais effectivement c'est c'est un mal
être de la fonction publique que le
gouvernement les gouvernements
successifs parce que je ne veux pas
faire de politique ici je ne parle pas
de celui là mais aussi de tous ses
précédents ont laissé pourrir
pour finir à une exaspération alors on
va parler du fond et aussi de quelques
bonne nouvelle parce que vous appelez ce
soir les pompiers à mettre fin cette
mobilisation ce mouvement de grève vous
vous étiez à la place beauvau
aujourd'hui racontez nous écoutez depuis
depuis une semaine le ministre de
l'intérieur nous avait écrit une
communication pour accepter le principe
d'une revalorisation de notre prime de
feu
sachant que nous redonne nous demandons
une prime de feu d'un taux de 2 28% et
qu'actuellement elle est à 19% nous nous
avons eu une proposition de la monter à
25% et notre syndicat avait accepté ce
principe de revalorisation tout en se
disant que dans le futur on demanderait
finalement en alignement comme sur la
police par exemple avec leurs primes
spécifiques étaient 28% ont demandé à
peu près les mêmes choses et on
reviendra dessus plus tard dans les
années qui viennent parce que pour
l'instant se contente de 25% à cause des
difficultés budgétaires des
collectivités territoriales où on est
bien conscient qu effectivement ils vont
avoir du mal forcément toujours à
trouver des budgets et donc on est un
peu raisonnable et on se contente de 25%
pour le moment mais c'est ce sont des
éléments que nous avions depuis une
grosse semaine et c'est pour ça que
notre syndicat cet après midi n'avait
pas appelé à manifester et donc
le ministre nous a juste confirmé ce qui
les exclut une semaine alors pourquoi
votre avis et manifestations de vos
collègues
aujourd'hui à paris alors bon il aurait
il leur appartient d'avoir voulu
jusqu'au jusqu'au bout de vouloir cette
prime à 28% et je me félicite que
finalement ils acceptent le principe de
le mettre à 25%
mais il reste cependant un des choses
que sur lequel nous voulons discuter
notamment sur la fin de carrière des
sapeurs pompiers
parce que il ya quand même encore des
éléments qui nous inquiète et peut-être
aussi qu'il avait voulu me cristalliser
leur leur mobilisation pour penser
seulement vous revendiquez vous aviez
des revendications du côté du régime des
retraites où ça en est cette ce pan des
négociations écoutez les
sapeurs-pompiers sont rassurés sur un
point c'est qu'ils sont encore
considérés comme un métier dangereux
certes nous sommes depuis 2004 et mai en
compte de la pénibilité dans votre cas
alors c'est pas tout à fait la
pénibilité que connaissent d'autres
salariés prévues dans le code du travail
on a vraiment un statut particulier on
nous dit que nous sommes dans une
catégorie selon les propos du ministre
dans une catégorie active et dangereuse
et qu'à ce titre on va nous maintenir
une possibilité de départ anticipé
donc on pourra
continuer de partir à 57 ans après
toutefois on a une inquiétude sur le
fameux hd qui lie brouage pivot que le
gouvernement compte bien mettre en place
pour toutes les catégories y compris les
sapeurs-pompiers et ça voudrait dire
qu'un pompier qui a toutes ses annuités
ne pourraient pas partir à 57 ans sans
décote et ça ça nous gêne et ça vous
n'avez pas été rassuré sur ce point bien
coûter on nous dit que c'est encore un
arbitrage que c'est pas fait donc
lorsque les décrets d'application
sortiront pour cette catégorie tv
dangereuse on nous consultera dont acte
j'aime à penser que l'on fera fléchir la
position du gouvernement les tuer parce
que c'est vraiment inacceptable dans le
cadre de quelqu'un qui réalise un métier
dangereux de laisser sur le terrain
alors qu'il a déjà tous et hannut et il
ya d'autres dates de négociation qui
sont prévus d'autres rendez-vous alors
pas sur ce sujet là sur les retraites et
d'ailleurs il passera la main au
secrétaire d'état qui gère les retraites
ce sera plus lui qui jouait qui gérera
ce taux si merci beaucoup yannick hamon
résident avoir été avec nous en direct
sur arte france merci à vous